it.
>> Sophia saifi, thank you.
We'll check in with you again
shortly.
>>> Thousands protesting in
South Africa last week demanding
realistic action against the
prolonged energy crisis.
For months now the country has
been facing rolling blackouts
which have crippled the economy
and paralyzed major cities.
For let's go to David Mackenzie
who joins us live from
johannesburg.
Actually the problem goes back
years, doesn't it?
>> Reporter: That's right.
It goes back to at least 2007,
max.
In the last few months you have
seen the disas Strauss effect of
lack of planning and general
chaos and corruption at the
energy utility here in south
Africa.
It has a massive impact on the
economy and just ordinary south
Africans and have to say some of
these images may be disturbing.
Tens of thousands of dead birds.
Suffocated when the power failed
and surges blew the backup
systems.
It's the awful impact of a
country in crisis.
When you saw thousands of
chickens die like this, what was
it like for you?
>> Glass of cold water in your
face.
It was so, so bad.
>> Reporter: He has struggled
with up to ten hours of rolling
blackouts a day.
He can't hide his anger at the
government.
>> I'm not asking them to do me
a favor.
I I will do my job and produce
food and wake up early, work on
Sundays to produce food for
South Africa.
I like what I'm doing.
Just do your job.
You have one thing to do, just
do it.
Just give us power, please.
>> Reporter: But power is in
short supply.
The farm they built from scratch
now runs at a loss during the
worst blackouts.
He says diesel costs could sink
them.
The president himself has
admitted corruption, sabotage, a
lack of skills has caused this
issue.
Why should this government be
trusted to fix it.
>> David, as you know this
predates the president's time in
government.
>> Reporter: Even the president
now acknowledges that decades of
mismanagement and breathtaking
corruption crippled state owned
escom, a lack of maintenance, a
deep skills deficit an
regulatory red tape has helped
cause this.
>> I will repeat the same
question which is why should
south Africans trust the
government that caused this
problem to fix this problem?
>> We accept those mistakes.
I've said it and the president
has said it numerous times there
were massive regrettable policy
missteps that led us to where we
are now, however, now we're
focusing on the solution and the
opportunities that have been
presented by this crisis.
>> For energy security.
>> Reporter: Not everyone is
buying it.
The official opposition is
calling for mass action.
You can sense the growing
frustration in South Africa
already.
This crisis isn't just
inconvenient for people, it can
kill the dreams of a better
future.
A better future is what this
family strives for.
Are you proud of yourself?
>> Yes, I am.
But we used to fight a lot.
>> Okay, that's caramel.
>> Reporter: He turned a small
government covid grant into the
soweto creamery.
It's a huge hit here thanks to
the whole family.
But when the power goes out,
their profits evaporate.
>> So now about to turn on the
generator.
>> Reporter: Their plans to
expand put on hold.
What do you want the government
to do?
>> I want the government to be
brutally honest with us.
If they're able to fix it,
please fix it.
If they can't they must let us
know and makes us feel we are
not really in a democracy
because it's meant for the
people by the people but it's as
if for them by them.
>> Reporter: At the very least
he and all south Africans just
want the lights to be turned
back on.
You really can feel the
frustration of millions of south
Africans, max, who feel they are
not being met with the support.
In some cases just to get
themselves out of poverty or
feed the nation and this has
broader implications.
Protests, you mentioned.
More have been planned for later
in February and in March.
It threatens the stability of
this country and could take